hey guys it's justine happy st patrick's
day i am here with my sister jenna hello
today we are gonna make shamrock shakes
and also cream cheese
cones i wanted to just make the shamrock
shake for a video i was like that's
like one simple thing like basically
we're blending ice cream and dyeing it
green
and that's it that sounds like a
stomachache waiting to happen it does
but it's gonna be so delicious it will
be
so not only we're gonna make the
shamrock shakes which is one of my
favorite things for mcdonald's ever do
you remember we came back from where we
yes
and i bought a shamrock shake at
mcdonald's and about lost my mind i
ordered it from the little machine
i picked it and then it just showed up
do you think this will be better than
that
i don't know probably not really setting
your expectations on it you got to set
your expectations super low
so that when anything goes moderately
well you're just like wow this
explorations have been exceeded your box
is wet
there's been a lot of rain in los
angeles and all my groceries because i
don't actually go to the store
they were on my doorstep and getting
rained off very soggy
super pink the cones are soggy no i
think they're in paper or plastic
but the cones are for cheesecake what
the heck are these i don't know i was
looking for something that was no bake
no bake shamrock shake cheesecake cones
let's get started the first thing that
we're gonna need is cream cheese we need
powdered sugar we've got
that oh i scared myself
oh my goodness i think we need a bowl oh
i've got you oh i love having a sous
chef i don't think that's where the
bowls are
bigger smaller bigger that's funny
because look how many bowls are in here
there's a lot of rolls for someone that
actually does not cook or bake
other than making videos because a lot
of things this is like a full plunge
there's a whole
there's a whole nother drawer of bowls
over here so the first thing we're going
to need to do is beat the cream cheese
sugar and extracts until creamy
how do i beat them with a beater do you
think i use a beater do i use my hand
no get the things do you think this goes
in here
um how many hours are you half cup
powdered sugar
wait sugar what are you doing what
what's the problem here
this one's the trouble one
oh shut up you got a half cup over there
of what
liquid or dry it doesn't matter whoa
yeah it does
dry do i beat the cream cheese now i
mean we're gonna beat it soon
i'm just like ready now yeah we gotta
put in this oh we need a vanilla extract
can you grab some vanilla from brussels
no no i didn't go anywhere yet yes then
oh my god that smells like oh
we'll just put a little bean paste
i don't know if that's before three
fourth what
almost knocked the light over that's not
it that's
oh that smells incredible no this is
this is pure bitterness wait wait
purvin oh help no are you okay i'm
a strong independent woman but i might
fall down
that's enough you didn't measure since
when am i about that measuring life
careful character it doesn't go lower
careful it's gonna start good things are
gonna i don't know what you want me to
do
that smells lovely i'm gonna put the
things back that we've already used
not it's not mixing together it
room temperature cream cheese this seems
to be cold cream cheese
[Applause]
these are questions that you have asked
and i have
not an answer for you i'll get a spatula
i'm so fancy okay so we've got a problem
so here okay so we have a few problems
um
what's next what oh no
okay how about this oh just yeah that's
good perfect that's incredible you're so
smart oh my god oh my god i'm sorry this
says refrigerate the mixture for at
least an hour
guess who's not doing that who has time
put in the freezer for
six minutes that was a very interesting
taste that i have just tasted
do i need this anymore i'm not sure i'm
gonna put it here
i don't know what are we making i forgot
how much do we need um ow my finger
hurts
to fold in two cups like this type of
cup no i think we just kind of like use
our measurement
no wait look on the side of the thing
what's it say
who's going to get a tummy ache today me
me too this
says i think tyler's going to get a
tummy he's going to get something
i'm just going to scoot yes we don't
want to use it all because we need to
save some of it for the top
have a look at this about a cup and a
half my shirt's falling off because i'm
a slob do i put this in here yeah we're
gonna fold it in
fold it that lovely this isn't folding
either but i think that
your internet installation is coming in
29 minutes
this is sort of like oil and water hold
the bowl for me eat the cream cheese
it's so creamy do you want to use a
whisk no
do you need help do you i think we're
good
that's nice okay this looks like just
fine
i'm gonna put this in the freezer while
we work on our shamrock shakes
okay what do we need ice cream
you have to just have days for like i've
been having a
i think i've been having a year and
having 12 months we we're so excited
about 2018 being over because we have a
it was a bit of a struggle and then 2019
got here and it was like can we have
2018 back
can we joke's on you joke's on me joke's
on you
one and one-fourth cups of milk
did i get the wrong kind no
it smells cold
yeah okay we need two cups of ice cream
well here's the problem i use the ice
cream scoop for the cool twit you did
you
what are you even doing
i think i have another scooper that'll
work too
oh look at that that's super unique of
you
this is so incredibly easy like you're
basically putting ice cream
and milk into a blender got the mint in
oh two tablespoons of chocolate syrup so
i thought i had chocolate syrup but i
cleaned my fridge out
and it was rotten
[Laughter]
just doesn't look healthy it looks
really good i am
loving it make sure the cap is on or
else
where are my cups at this point i guess
i could have got them this looks like a
milkshake
option you look like a milkshake oh
oh that's a little soupy
that's a little soupy i did get
ready with oh that's disgusting
we can't use straws because the internet
doesn't allow us to use straws anymore
because it's bad for the environment
so we don't use them anymore i get it
you should get into metal straws
we'll just put a lot of cream in this
one
do you have like a stick a stick oh
you're just sticking your hands in there
yeah okay that i mean honestly i wash my
hands
when look at that shamrock shake
i'm sorry
how was it it tastes like i put
peppermint extract
into a blender with ice cream and milk
i'll tell you what though it's very
pepperminty the whipped cream is
incredible
are shamrock shakes pepperminty
yeah here tyler get a tummy tickle
you don't have to you don't have to but
um tastes like the holidays
um oh come on
i don't have a beard that's really good
oh my god
like i am like like i already have to go
to the bathroom
let's let maddie out let's get you oh
yeah
let manny give a lick
[Music]
that is it that give him kisses give him
kisses meg that's like a puppetino
[Music]
oh my god he's terrified
he's unsure he also won't take food from
justine's mouth i know i always try to
get him to take like egg out of my mouth
it's so dumb oh my gosh well that's this
is content
this is content this is at 25 minutes i
don't want it to cut
all right well we're going to clean up
and we'll be back with the cones
this is content spool they are very
small
do you like a rack this one's for um
this is not it
take that back that's useless i
definitely have them before yeah let's
put it in the toaster
no yeah this is fine
so the soaster isn't plugged in that
didn't work
look i've i've made a mistake i think i
am i am
call me macgyver call me bear grylls
where it's gonna it's not there's no
it's
no i'm already feeling the tummy tickle
from that
previous snack yeah for sure oh my god
yeah this is working so perfect
like it's actually working perfectly
but you didn't what are you doing
like that one you can't do anything with
it
we have one more left we only you have
another toaster
what other appliances can we put it in
that looks nice
what about a cup oh what about my mouth
now you've soiled it
this is really good but i don't like it
so we basically just taste tested it i
just don't want okay there we go
that's
[Music]
so what we can do to taste test
pretty good so i think that this is
something that you can make for like a
picnic
or like a st patrick's day
date like
you can show up to your date store baby
i made you a cream cheese stone i'd be
like what
i'd be like take me now i'm yours
this is really great i'm not gonna lie
i don't think i would eat this unless
like i was eating forester
not very good no to be honest with you
the dog is upset
well thank you guys for watching oh my
god i gotta go hope that you moderately
enjoy this video
don't make that go check out jenna's
channel and
happy st patrick's day
okay okay okay
i was gonna put sprinkles on it but
honestly it doesn't freaking matter no
okay this video is over now
[Music]